the jurgen experience you brought this
up early and i wanted to ask you now
like
you were talking about like physical
stuff like you get angry and you get
anxiety
because like you you don't you you let
yourself get overweight
like how much does that [ __ ] with you
and how much would you give to not have
that anymore
like isn't that wouldn't i mean if
there's one major thing that keeps
[ __ ] with you over and over again
that you could fix i have that's a fixed
one right
you could fix that so i have a disease
of more like i was saying that i have a
a chasm a black hole that it doesn't
matter
how many women i have sex with how many
porn i've jerked off to how much money
i've gambled
and lost in one small fortunes huge
fortunes
i i have had an eating disorder which is
like
i thought that was a girl thing that's
what i thought like i got to
when i went to rehab for gambling
addiction
it was this is the first rehab i've went
to i've been to every [ __ ] rehab
mental health wellness center in america
now um
i said hey do you guys deal with process
addiction and they're like i sure come
over and when i went there
there was only meth heads there they
didn't even know they just wanted my
money yeah i just come over here
and i learned there like serious
gambling addiction
like one out of four kills themselves
and yeah it's it's a
it's the reason why there's no balconies
in las vegas
the only place that has balconies is the
cosmo i think and they had like two
suicides the first month they opened
i think because you're
so i i i'm like i have things
that when i talk about it it's funny
can't stop jerking off
can't it's all i can't stop working just
[ __ ]
got a emmy working for vice and i got my
podcast and i got this and i got this
next project and my next art show is
going to make a million dollars
you're addicted to that there's no end
to it right there's no
there's no nothing and when i meet when
i watch the jordan documentary and i
meet famous people that have succeeded
at the highest levels
i go how long are you happy for maybe a
day
maybe 24 hours and then what happens the
next day back to the grind
it's not enough got the gold medal back
to the grind back to the grind
and i go it's it's never going to be
enough
i'll never have enough women money
success it's it's this and i go
i have so many friends who've killed
themselves i have so many like bourdain
asked me for help he asked me for help
like
i'm like yes what did he say he said i'm
[ __ ] miserable
i'm miserable do you how do you deal
with this and i was like i've been
waiting for this [ __ ] phone call
thank you how how recent or how close to
when he died was that
it was within the year it wasn't like
right but so he said it was miserable
and
in what way to describe it he said
you're successful i'm successful do you
find yourself suffering and i go
absolutely please and then i called him
and uh and i this is what i mean when i
say
asking for help and receiving for help
that was a [ __ ] heart
you know people that know bourdain i
know his friends i know his manager
you won't find a [ __ ] person that
will say a bad thing about him
that guy is a [ __ ] he's so awesome
he's
always looking out for you he'll show up
for you whatever you need he'll take
care of you he's an amazing guy very
very interesting guy
and so you can't find anyone but i'm
like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you're an [ __ ] you murdered yourself
you murdered yourself you killed someone
that person happened to be you
but you couldn't even show up for
yourself you
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm getting real listen
i get it you love the guy i loved him
too
it's um
i've known many people that have killed
themselves now
it's a it's a very sad thing
that was that you can't you can never
fix that that sadness is always going to
be a part of you you're always going to
think
maybe i could have gotten to him maybe i
could have talked to him maybe if i was
there
but that was it he he did it he reached
out he's like i relate to you dave
i connect with you and i was like yes
so what did he wind up doing he i talked
to him
i said hey man here's all the things
i've done i'm i'm in a really good place
now i can help you i can i can refer you
to places
i got you and it was almost like
thank you for caring for me thank you
like he was he was
severe codependent like he was a people
pleaser right he's like i'm
like he never said no he's like i'm
gonna [ __ ]
help everybody except for myself
it's okay man i get it
so i'm gonna help everyone except for
myself
and i think i make this up in my head
he's like
and i've done this too before it's like
i kind of
half-ass ask people for help oh dave i
got resources and then i go
that's enough just to know that you
cared and that i know that there's
places i can go to
that's enough i don't have to actually
full stop my life and change until
you know oh [ __ ] so that's what i mean
when you say
we don't as a culture people don't teach
us this [ __ ]
people don't teach us how how to how to
[ __ ] ask for help
and then receive help
[Applause]